[shutter clicks]
- [giggles]
- "I have these shoes.
#MothersDay."
[phone chimes]
[knock at door]
- Hey, Tanz-manian devil,
how's it going? Cool response.
Look,
I just wanted to warn you--
How do I put this eloquently?
Your man is downstairs
about to go downstairs
on another man.
- What? Dan's back?
- I know, girlfriend.
I feel you, but sometimes
people get back together.
It's like everyone
always said to me, you know,
"When you turn 25, Gene,
you're gonna
start wanting a family."
And guess what?
I do.
I want my OG mom and my OG dad
to live that OG lifestyle.
OG stands for "Only Gene."
- I will not let this happen.
- Oh, no.
I-I didn't want you
to get upset and go downstairs
and add a little spice
to the scene downstairs, no.
- I'm sorry, Gene,
but I'm getting my man back.
- Good!
I mean, or boo.
Or do whatever.
[engine starts]
[engine revs]
- The hell is he doing?
- I think he's gonna jump
over the fire.
- I'm in love,
and her name's Millie.
- Billie!
- You bet.
- That's me. I'm Billie.
This is for me.
[heavy metal music]
Go!
[gasps]
Pony, no!
- Don't be upset.
- Come on.
- You remember that--
you remember that trip to Italy?
It was so amazing.
- Amazing times.
- It was so amazing.
- Do you remember the thing you
kept doing in Naples?
You don't?
- I don't remember anything
about Naples.
- Come on.
You kept calling
Naples "nipples" the whole time.
You know, it really
wasn't all that funny at first,
but you just kept doing it!
- More, please.
- Oh, [bleep], that's good.
- Where the hell is Tanzy?
- It looks
like you don't need her.
- You're right, Joy.
I need to take matters
into my own hands.
I didn't want to have
to do this,
but it's not
like I wasn't prepared.
Wish me luck.
- You are all right,
Mr. and Mrs. Good.
- You're all right.
- You are good.
- Hey, Mom and Dad,
how 'bout a tune.
[guitar strums]
♪ Let's get--
- You want this?
Is this what you want?
You want me to be a man?
You want my husband, don't you?
- No.
- Well back off!
'Cause he's mine, bitch!
- Ow!
- Tanzy!
You apologize this instant!
- No, it's okay.
We're all grown-ups here.
We can handle this like adults.
- All right.
- [screams]
[somber organ music]
♪ ♪
[screaming]
- Stop! Stop it! Stop it!
- Get off of her!
- That's it.
- No biting! No biting!
- You're crazy!
- And what? And what? And what?
- Take her inside!
Take her--take her inside.
- Don't talk like that.
- I'm gonna kill you.
- Oh, my God.